as pride month continues so do the
celebrations hyperx the luxors esports
arena is hosting a meetup this sunday a
gamer meetup this sunday here to tell us
more this is kevin forstrom their
esports manager welcome to the show hey
how's it going thanks for having me it's
great to have you if someone hasn't been
to hyperx what are you guys what takes
place over there yes so we are a gaming
facility we do a lot of tournaments uh
gaming themed events so this uh
that leads us into this next event we're
doing a pride event with our local
gaming scene
uh for lgbtq plus gamers uh to kind of
meet up and have a great time so and
this is happening on sunday yes what can
we expect on sunday so we are going to
be starting off with some mario kart
some mario parties classics switch
sports all sorts of kind of like fun
casual games for people to kind of get
involved get excited and have a great
time we're also going to have some free
game play available for anybody who
wants to come in and really just kind of
integrate with the community and have a
good time it's a great way to who
doesn't like to play video games this is
a great way to connect over video games
why was this important for you guys to
do this event well it's really important
for the arena to be inclusive we have a
lot of people on our team who really
feel strongly and passionately about uh
like lgbtq plus all sorts of pride
obligations things like that and we're
really just excited to to have that and
just continue being inclusive and adding
more to our community and it starts at
six o'clock five o'clock five o'clock
and we're talking free game play yes
okay out of those games you mentioned
what's your favorite
oh uh super smash brothers is one that i
didn't quite say but we are going to be
featuring super smash brothers ultimate
as well and that's probably my favorite
game and people come down there and they
do video game competitions they're
competing against other people across
the country talk more about the arena
yeah so we do all sorts of different
tournaments all throughout uh or
throughout the year uh we do like super
smash brothers we do valorent league of
legends uh we've done fortnight in the
past we've done every game you can
really think of good fall harry
okay maybe not all of them ha ha i
stumped them
but uh yeah no we do a lot of really
cool uh
like events my responsibility is to run
all of our community events and first
party uh tournaments so anything you see
that comes through our venue is
typically
through me it's a great event on sunday
i'm going to put you on the spot here
because it was just announced this week
the grammys they have a new category
where they include video game scores
what is the best video game score oh
this would be a great question for my
girlfriend
uh i uh
of all time we'll take it of all time of
all time i would say halo
the halo theme song is incredible uh i'm
also a big star fox fan so star fox 64
theme is always killer why is halo the
best soundtrack it's nostalgic like when
you played halo back in the day it's
like it hits it's got the it's got the
gregorian chanting it's so cool it's
such a great song and uh the new one
came out this last year and it like
really kind of like that that wave of
nostalgia came over is that we i think i
think we're hearing it right now the
halo
we're hearing we're hearing i just love
how you said it's nostalgic the halo
okay we said that i'm thinking pac-man
i'm thinking mario brothers i mean i'm
going old-school right and you're
talking about a game that came out about
2000 2001 yeah this is the age
difference right here
i appreciate it thank you so much how do
we get more information uh so you can go
to the hyperx arena las vegas website uh
we are always available with our
schedule on there we also have a discord
channel that you can always uh check
into which is uh discord gg allied
esports i love it all of our information
is on those too do you remember the pong
old school
of course kendall was the master of that
game that was his game i was gonna be
the self-deprecating one on that